hello everyone this next game was played
in the 2016 ultimate bliss challenge in
Saint Louis its place between Gannicus
borrow and Westley so and I just want to
wanted to say that I always enjoy
watching Gary play the scotch because he
really started the opening during his
1990 World Championship match in lyon
against the anatoly karpov so he really
understands the position that arise from
this opening and you know its secrets
and poisons so let's see the game cuz
pyro is white and he plays efore we have
E 5 9 2 a 3 Knight to c6 d 4e capture
Sundy for the Scotch Knight captures on
d4 Knight to f6 and here casparo goes
for the Schmitt variation Knight
captures on c6 we have B casters on c6
and now e5 Wesley plays Queen t7 pinning
the pawn we have Queen TV - and now nice
a d5 because power plays c4 and Bishop
to a six now pinning this point we have
b3 g7 g 6 Bishop to a3 attacking the
Queen and Wesley pushes c5 so we have g3
Bishop to g7 + f4 and although this was
a blitz game Kasparov really played it
like it was a bullet game who really
understood what was going on here so it
plays nice to be four we have a bishop
to g2 attacking the rook on a8 so rook a
rook to d8 Knight to c3 and here
Wesley castles we have a bishop back to
b2 and b5 by Wesley so and here has
power plays a3 this Knight can't really
move away from before because well this
bond will fall censor the knight and the
bishop are attacking it so Wesley
decides to push d4 Kasparov place a
casters on b4 we have D captures on c3
and Bishop captures on c3 and now seek
after some before and the bishop goes
back Bishop to b2 and now this power of
is detecting this Bishop on a6
so what's the place is Bishop to c8 and
in this position because part of could
have captured this pawn on a 7
he doesn't want to allow rope captures
on a seven and Queen to c5 attacking the
rook and also disabling white from
castling because because Farah of like I
always say favorite favours activity
above all and he doesn't want to give up
his activity over over one pawn so after
Bishop to c8 Kasparov decided to castle
and here Wesley so definitely should
have considered a move like Queen to c5
check to get a hold of this strong
diagonal here and maybe we should have
five next and something like that but he
played f6 trying to break the white
standard and I remember watching this
game live and Marisa Marisa actually and
Yasser were you know discussing that
Bishop to d5 check is the strongest
engine move but willpower will be able
to see it in a blitz game but because
part of actually instance we played
Bishop to b5 check and this is the
critical position of the game and it's
it's well it's interesting what the
black can play here he does have to
calculate a lot because you have a
different poisonous line of waiting like
King to a chase for example and then e
captures on f6 if black would cap
provides Queens and you have F captures
on g7 with checkmate and even if you
don't capture the Queen you have
something like the Bishop captures I
have six and Queen captures on e7 and
the bishop cannot capture the Queen
because it's been so there are all sorts
of ideas here probably after it captures
on f6 whether it would have to play
something like Queen to c5 check and
then figuring out to what to do next but
it's what the Blitz game in it wasn't at
all clear what would happen here so
after Bishop to g5 check Wesley decided
to play rook captures on d5 to give up
the exchange so because power plays seek
after some d5 and now Wesley plays Queen
to c5 check the power plays rook to f2
and now F captures an e5 we have Bishop
captures on e5 Bishop captures on e5 and
Queen captures on e5 and now what's the
place are up to d8 going for that D pawn
so the fireplace erupted
b1 we have Bishop to g4 attacking the
rook we have Queen to d4 attacking the
black screen so Queen to a5 and now rook
to D - D - D - we have rook to e8 and
King to g2 just getting out of the first
rank you know to avoid any checks and
tricks so where's the place Queen to b5
we have h3 kicking the bishop a bishop -
f5g for kicking the bishop again 54
check and now King to h2 and Wesley
plays a c5 so a Gary place Queen to f6
we have c4 and the spiral disregards
this and pushes his own past pawn d6
so we have Bishop to c6 preventing d7
and the fireplace f5 he wants to break
through to attack the King s captures on
g6 would be deadly now so what's the
place rook to f8 attacking the Queen we
have 26 checked King to g7 and here we
could fire replace d7 and well is
threatening the Queen and d8 but Wesley
tries one more idea he plays the Queen
to c5 and in this position well Garry
Kasparov just played the Queen to d6
although it's interesting to see what
happened if gas power plays pawn to DA
and gets a Queen you will get something
like the point to d8 queen of black
would capture here and Weiss would
simply play F captures on g6 threatening
Queen to f7 check and queen to h7 check
so black would probably has to play
something like rook to f8 and you will
get a rope to f7 check rook afters on f7
Queen captures on f7 and other King can
go to h h8 because it's made so King to
h6 you'd get into h7 check and Esther
King to g5
Queen to h5 check and King therefore and
picking up the queen but Parham doesn't
go for four counts of calculating a long
line like this
it's a bleep game so in this position
because part of just plays Queen to d6 a
normal human move that makes what we saw
resigned instantly because well he's
attacking his queen and if they
exchanged Queens
well the bishop is attacked and this
point is ready to become a queen this
can be stopped so yeah like I said after
a Queen to d6 what was so resigned and
yeah I always enjoy watching Gary play
the Scotch even Nakamura fell victim in
this tournaments to Gary Scott and I
wonder who will be brave enough and the
same foolish rapid this year to play the
Scotch against Gary Kasparov so let's
begin
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
I will see you soon